[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
premier rendez vous de la semaine
pour ma part je me sens très apaisé car
j'ai deux médecins autour de moi si
jamais je me sens mal bonsoir laurent
alexandre soit vous êtes chirurgien
entrepreneurs essayiste cofondateur du
site doctissimo qui est toujours en tête
des audiences dans cette spécialité des
conseils médicaux
votre dernier livre jouissez jeunesse a
été publié aux éditions lattès et nous
accueillons aussi patrick peloux bonsoir
vous êtes médecin urgentiste vous
présidez l'association des médecins
urgentistes de france
vous avez été on s'en souvient bien
chroniqueur à charlie hebdo est votre
dernier livre est une très belle
déclaration
mieux vaut mourir debout que vivre à
genoux chez robert laffont
nous comme mon sens il vous le voulez
bien par faire un petit point sur
l'épidémie de coronavirus et son
traitement focalisons-nous si vous le
voulez bien sûr l'école
désormais il ya une nouvelle règle une
classe ne ferme plus quand il y à un
élève qui est qu'à contacter il en faut
trois comme l'a confirmé ce matin le
ministre de l'éducation nationale à
notre consoeur alba ventura sur rtl on
ne ferme plus la classe pour un seul cas
c'est bien ça le nouveau protocole c'est
ce que le haut conseil de santé publique
a dit et que nous suivons donc c'est
plutôt quand il ya trois cas qu'on
serait en situation de de fermer une
classe
et par ailleurs il n'a plus de 14 mai
une septantaine mais ça c'est la règle
générale patrick peloux ça vous paraît
des mesures de bon sens oui ça rejoint
d'ailleurs ce qu'ont dit les pédiatres
vers le mois de mai où il fallait se
colorise et les enfants c'est à dire que
on commençait à avoir des prémices de
gamins qui sortaient du système scolaire
d'ailleurs il y en a encore quelques
milliers qui sont pas retournés à
l'école et sas a posé plus de problèmes
que de savoir qu'ils avaient un risque
d'être cas contacts et de
potentiellement véhicule et le virus on
doit vivre avec ce virus
combien de temps personne ne sait
comment ça va évoluer
bah c'est le virus qui le dit avec sa
propre écologie on voit comment il
évolue à l'heure actuelle faut pas
paniquer il faut pas avoir peur mais il
faut plus arrêter la société parce que
les dommages sociaux et notamment donc
pour l'école et pour les études les
élèves les étudiants
ça sera plus dramatique que les
conséquences lui même dû du virus pour
eux donc c'est vraiment un enjeu de
société
on a vraiment une nouvelle maladie qui
est arrivé sur terre ça c'est sûr on va
pas tarder à arriver à un million de
morts sur la planète
bon il faut continuer à vivre et vivre
avec c'est pour ça que vous avez les
mesures barrières le port du masque le
lavage hydro alcoolique et on n'est pas
du tout à ce jeu je le redis à chaque
fois on n'est pas du tout dans le cas de
figure du mois de mars et avril
pas du tout laurent alexandre bonne une
bonne mesure
oui je suis d'accord il faut va falloir
qu'on vivre avec
on ne sait pas quand on aura un vaccin
on peut espérer qu'on ait des vaccins
expérimentaux janvier janvier février
mars mais ça n'est pas une certitude on
n'est pas ce 1021 en 2021 on n'est pas
certain qu'ils donneront une protection
satisfaisante
il n'y a pas de traitement antiviral
dont il ya pas de médicaments
spécifiques contre le médicament
l'hydroxyde chloroquine ne marche pas
c'est maintenant aujourd'hui avéré en
revanche on a fait des progrès sur le
taux de mortalité en réanimation a à peu
près été dit
et par deux tirs le nombre de morts en
réanimation été divisé par deux la
moitié de cette baisse est liée à la
dexaméthasone qu'on se quitte à
corticoïdes et qu'on utilise bien dans
certaines formes graves et puis
l'amélioration de l'oxygénothérapie de
la réanimation spécifique explique
l'autre moitié de cette amélioration
donc de toutes façons la deuxième vague
même si elle l avait la même gravité
apparente que la première on aurait deux
fois moins de morts
donc il faut qu on vit avec on ne peut
pas arrêter la société on peut pas avoir
une dépression modèle 1929
donc on est obligé d'accepter un certain
risque et mène on est en train de
l'arrêter à nouveau la société regarder
ce qui se passe
il ya certains quartiers de madrid qui
sont re confiner ces locales ce ne sont
pas des confinement généralisée c'est à
dire qu'effectivement il ya des zones où
ça va mal
madrid marseille va pas bien on peut pas
exclure qu'ils aient déconfinement
localisé à marseille en octobre novembre
vu la dynamique actuelle de saturation
possible des services de réanimation à
marseille donc on va faire au cas par
cas localement et on va ruser avec cette
maladie qu'on commence un petit peu à
comprendre
en attendant qu'on est peut-être un
vaccin ou que le virus disparaît
spontanément il ya des pandémies qui
disparaissent parce que le cycle viral
le permettre ça ne dit plus qu'il faut
tout dire le le oui notre constat sur le
terrain
là c'est qu'il a la virulence la
pathogénicité du virus est moindre
d'accord donc ça c'est globalement
rassurants mais on n'en est pas sûr
qu'on n'avait pas sûr on n'en est pas
sûr mais mais quand même vous votre
intuition ce qui l'est moins méchant il
est moins méchant ou alors il s'est
habitué ce qui est une théorie d'un
certain nombre de virologues 10 le virus
y suis un petit peu avec avec sa
transmission
donc il faut voir la seule chose c'est
qu'on évitera le confinement si en effet
tout citoyen quel que soit son âge
respecte les gestes barrières et les
masques
or c'est exact notamment dans le sud qui
sont toujours des villes de fête et de
convivialité
bon bah voilà passé la troisième femme
de bière les masses qui saute et c'est
là un étudiant on chez les étoiles dans
les fêtes d'étudiants voilà et c'est çà
çà çà çà c'est regrettable moi je
voudrais juste
rappeler aux étudiants que nous avons
des cas graves chez des étudiants
c'est pas que les personnes âgées les
myocardite c'est souvent chez les jeunes
bien sûr vous réagissez sur internet sur
lefigaro.fr sur le hashtag point de vue
et puis voici ce que vous en pensez le
protocole qu'ovide pour l'école présenté
par jean michel blanquer re est il
raisonnable
et bien c'est non à 60% parmi les les
internautes qui ont répondu alors pour
être tout à fait honnête on vous demande
pas pourquoi vous trouvez que c'est pas
raisonnable parce que c'est trop est ce
que ce n'est pas assez
moi j'ai quand même une question que
répondez vous à ceux qui disent regardez
à l'école on en a fait trop ont fermé
une classe avec un cas avec finalement
trois cas ça suffit on mettait les gens
à l'écart 14 jours finalement c'est
toujours ça suffit est-ce que c'est pas
une illustration du principe de
précaution n'ont porté porté trop loin
il ya deux sujets il ya un an on a voulu
établir un principe de précaution bomba
le principe de précaution c'est de
prendre soin et d'anticiper le plus
possible donc c'est sûr que le curseur
le temps de le savoir à quel niveau mais
il a fallu ajuster parce que cette
maladie est arrivée on ne la connaissais
pas mais depuis le début on disait que
les enfants ce n'était pas dangereux
parce que au début on pensait que ce
n'était pas dangereux et souvenez-vous
quand d'un coup il ya eu quelques cas de
pédiatrie le tout la presse sans
l'opinion afghane et dé fignon a paniqué
on s'est retrouvé avec tous les médias à
l'hôpital necker c'était un siège de
caméras d'accord parce que tout le monde
avait peur un quart où il ya un service
qu'il ya un bel hôpital d'enfants
malades très connu bon le truc c'est que
on a appris de plus en plus acceptée il
faut pas oublier non plus que les
informations qui t'arrive et chine est
totalement fausse d'accord les chinois
auront totalement menti bon donc du coup
on est parti on était à l'aveuglé on ne
savait pas où on allait principe de
précaution fallait protéger les enfants
parce que l'on sait on s'est tous dit y
compris dans le milieu médical
oh là là si ça touche les enfants et que
c'est dramatique pour les enfants alors
là c'est vraiment le drame absolu
bon et puis on a on
réussi à nuancer et on adapte encore on
est passé de 14 jours pour isoler les
gens à sept jours voilà et je pense que
ça va continuer à évoluer et à évoluer
dans les principes et en fait ce qui se
passe à l'école sera de toute façon
décliné après dans les autres systèmes
et je pense notamment au théâtre mais on
découvre on découvre petit à petit au
début on a cru effectivement il y avait
des vasques eu l'art est extrêmement
gras à 20 r d atteindre vasculaire
inflammatoires chez les enfants en grand
nombre en fait c'était pas le cas on a
un moment pense à l'amnésie de kawasaki
exactement on a pensé que les anti
inflammatoires non stéroïdiens alba
grave est la maladie
ensemble ça ça ne semble pas si enfin le
pied les gens qui les prennent
avant le vote la somme pas massivement
comme on l'avait créé de gros on pilote
il faut pas oublier qu'au moment où nous
parlons là de nous sommes fin septembre
nous ne connaissons cette maladie que
depuis dix mois depuis décembre 2019
donc il faut du temps pour connaître un
virus il faut des années et des années
aujourd'hui on au pilote du mieux qu'on
peut mais on va rester dans le flou dans
le wagon va rester dans un brouillard
épidémiologique et un brouillard médical
pendant encore de nombreux mois même si
on fait constamment des progrès dans la
prise en charge des malades alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est effectivement on a
maintenant plus plusieurs mois de recul
sur sur cette mode est mis moi je
voudrais vous montrer un graphique parce
que honnêtement ça fait plusieurs jours
que qui me trotte dans la tête
regardez c'est le taux de mortalité en
france le niveau de mortalité par dans
le nombre de morts par jour depuis le
1er mars est en jaune c'est l'année 2020
en rouge l'année 2019 en bleu l'année
2018 alors qu'est ce qu'on voit qu'il ya
eu un très gros pic avec on est monté
jusqu'à 2800 morts c'était le 1er avril
2020 que depuis ça redescend et que
depuis le mois de mai c'est exactement
la même heure qualité que les années
précédentes et l'insee ajoute du 1er mai
au 7 septembre 2010 la mortalité n'est
pas supérieur à l'année 2019 et elle
n'est supérieure que de 1% à l'année
2018 or on a des confiner le 11 mai et
il s'est rien passé
alors est ce que on part donc c'est un
peu obsessionnel mais est ce qu'on en
fait pas trop mais non vous avez raison
d'être obsessionnelle mais le
le nom justement cette courbe et ce pipe
que vous voyez c'est vraiment la course
typique d'une épidémie d'accord il s'est
passé un truc vers le mois de mars avril
et après ses revenus dans dans un niveau
normal de mortalité en france
probablement que c'est parce que les
gestes barrières sont respectés et c'est
pour ça je pense pas qu'on en fasse trop
c'est un principe de précaution mais
écoutez il ya pire que de porter un
masque et se laver et puis en plus de ça
parce que je pensais que c'est très bien
que les français se lavent plus les
mains qu'avant donc ça permet de faire
diminuer toutes les transmissions des
autres on n'a jamais eu aussi peu de
gastro entérite de l'été 1
cette année c'est assez bruyant et vous
allez voir que là on va battre des
records parce que en effet il faut se
vacciner contre la grippe d'accord et
ben vous allez voir que votre mortalité
va probablement chuter d'accord
probablement ce qui va y avoir moins de
grip cette année parce qu'on va tout
savoir le masque la vie d'emma se
vacciner et probablement que c'est on va
contribuer par le geste collectif tout
le monde de tout le monde
contribuer à diminuer l'épidémie jusqu'à
en effet quand est-ce qu'elle s'arrêtera
sa part qu'on personne c'est le c'est
comme la grippe
et comme la grippe représente pas mal de
morts chaque année avec les précautions
comprend et un taux élevé de vaccination
on va avoir une tendance naturelle
orco vide à une baisse de la mortalité
générale de la population toujours
quelqu'un vous avez entre 8000 et 10000
personnes qui meurent de la grippe
tremblant les mauvaises années quand 69
alors mais je reviens à mon graphique
laurent alexandre est ce qu'il est utile
de prendre toutes ces mesures
jour après jour on entend les préfets
qui donne des nouvelles contraintes
il ya des ehpad qui sont fermées aux
visites des services hospitaliers aussi
quand on voit que ben sahar par
l'amérique et sur n'est pas est-ce que
c'est emmerdant ou pas de faire
attention à ce que ces ultimes ont bien
combiné en or et de mort si on n'avait
pas confiné si on ne faisait pas
attention
c'est difficile à estimer mais on peut
raisonnablement penser qu'on serait
quelque part entre 150 et 250 mille
morts en france si on avait pris aucune
mesure
on peut on ne sait pas peut on peut
l'estimer même si c'est une 6 et
approximatif
on a cassé le pic
le premier pic par des mesures de
confinement et de distanciation qui
était extrêmement forte
aujourd'hui ce tableau s'arrête au 24
août
qu'est-ce qu'il va être en octobre
novembre si nous ne cassons pas la
petite deuxième vague actuelle on ne le
sait pas il ya des gens qui sont
pessimistes notamment dans le sud je
vois des gens j'ai des amis chirurgie à
marseille ça commence à chauffer un peu
dans les réanimations et les gens sont
inquiets si on avait une généralisation
de ce qui se passe en ce moment à
marseille on pourrait avoir une remontée
même si je le disais tout à l'heure il
est extrêmement propre peu probable
qu'on puisse avoir un pic de mortalité
équivalent à celui du 20 ans talent est
le problème le problème qu'elle a à
marseille c'est un problème chronique
donc on a dit oh là là ça chauffe à
marseille mais quand vous parlez avec
les urgent d'un nouvel attaquant de
l'asnl mode la chloroquine lens n'en
parlons pas fait ce que vous voulez on
parle de ce que vous voulez le problème
il ya c'est qu'il ya un problème
chronique d'autre part la situation des
hôpitaux va être tendu en effet parce
que là je suis pour ce qui est en train
d'être pris de ne pas reporter les
gestes chirurgicaux et la prise des
autres malades parce que il faut pas
focaliser tout le système de santé sur
juste le govic 19 d'accord ça c'est pas
possible c'est pas entendable là on est
en train dans les services des autres
spécialités c'est difficile de faire
revenir les malades les chirurgies
cancéreuses ont eu lieu cet été alors
qu'elle devait avoir lieu en avril mais
c'est du retard pour les malades
il n'y a pas que cette maladie est donc
là ce qui consisterait à à dire on va à
nouveau freiner tout système de santé et
plus consacrer que cas lakovic 19
en fait alors là pour le coup on aurait
vraiment des conséquences pires que
qu'avec la copie de 19 je pense qu'il
faut adapter le système de santé comme
comme à marseille
vous le disiez fort justement on sait
que maintenant l'oxygénothérapie très
très forte d'accord avec 38 minutes pour
les malades qui ont du mal à respirer
ça évite en fait l'incubation et tout ça
est donc on pense que par des prises en
charge plus adaptée dès le début des
symptômes qui sont un petit peu délicat
on à l'intubation moins importante on
attend un petit peu on a on a appris à
traiter les conséquences de ce virus
donc on est encore avec une évolution je
pense que c'est une évolution de
l'épidémie mais vraiment on n'est pas
dans le même schéma de du mois d'avril
de mars avril 1 parce que ça arrive et
il faut il faut voir quand neuf mois de
prise en charge
on a déjà diminuer la mortalité de cette
maladie de 50% pour diminuer la
mortalité du sida de 50%
il a fallu plus de vingt ans donc on est
allé extrêmement vite dans la diminution
de la mortalité spécifique au virus
donc il faut pas oublier ça on a été
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus vite que
le sida même si les deux maladies ne se
compare pas mais je veux dire on entend
en évolution de la mortalité on a fait
très vite
l'amélioration de la réanimation
spécifique est un vrai est un vrai
succès médical dont on ne parle pas on
est uniquement dans la polémique sur le
traitement totalement inefficace du
professeur à holt et on ne dit pas un
mot du vrai progrès qui est
l'amélioration de la prise en charge
merci d'en parler ça faut dire aux gens
c'est une spécialité qui est pas trop
connu la réanimation médicale et c'est
vraiment une spécialité qui a beaucoup
de mal
je lui dit au premier ministre cet été
il fallait augmenter considérablement le
nombre d' interne en réanimation
médicale
ils les ont augmenté de 1 il y en a
moins de 150 par an lemay est largement
insuffisant il faut - former 200 à 250
réanimateurs médicaux par an pour faire
face et augmenter notre nombre de lits
la france n'a que cinq mille cinq cents
lits de réanimation médicale c'est
insuffisant pour la fine il faut il faut
des moyens on ne peut pas dire patrick
peloux que vous ne l'ayez pas de la
suite dans vos convictions puisque vous
ne l'avez pas c'est souvent ce message
ici et il est entendu quelques
commentaires d'internautes sich sur
lefigaro.fr qu'on remette l'école par
correspondance avec éventuellement une
interro sur site par mois et ceux qui
n'ont pas la moyenne pourrait rester en
présentiel
oui chères' sauf qu'apparemment le sait
pas si dangereux que ça l'école et que
donc il est préférable d'y retourner en
tout cas c'est l'avis de patrick peloux
e pad wii est excellent comme j'ai pas
l'habitude de vous voir d'accord entre
vous c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal à me
faire à cette ce consensus
babineau sur lefigaro.fr nous dit qu ont
reproché au gouvernement de ne pas en
faire assez avant le confinement est
maintenant d'en faire trop c'est
compliqué oui c'est une question qu'on
sait très complices et nicole sur
lefigaro.fr les chiffres qu'on nous
assène tous les jours ne veulent pas
dire grand chose puisque maintenant on
teste par milliers oui sauf que le taux
de positivité dans les tests augmente
donc il s'est pas uniquement parce qu'on
teste plus qu'il ya c'est que les bus de
malades
et puis josy sur youtube nous dit enfin
peu cette question j'ai pas du tout la
réponse pourquoi en 2020 y at il eu que
72 morts de la grippe et pourquoi est-ce
qu'en suède gardent réunion finement il
ya eu moins de morts qu'en france alors
la comparaison avec la suède un gros
sujet donc on fera une autre fois mais
il n'y a pas beaucoup de morts de la
grippe cette année c'est vrai j'ai pas
spécifié si ça m'étonnerait il est une
autre sans doute que ce soit une année
où il ya moins de morts que la moyenne
et puis c'est pas le dernier mot sera
pour céline sur youtube avec cette forme
de 2,2 cri du coeur pour soutenir
patrick peloux peut-être qu'à force de
taper sur notre système de santé on
n'était pas prêts à gérer cette crise
alors
[Musique]
non ce que je retire de retient plutôt
de 7,2 cette phrase c'est qu'en fait on
n'avait pas mesuré la vaillance des
personnels hospitaliers que ce soit
hospitalier mais aussi du monde libéral
de ville et des cliniques privées
vous avez un système de santé
globalement qui s'est mis debout pour
faire face faut saluer en effet leur
citoyenneté et leur vaillance c'est
après après le débat sur les moyens
c'est autre chose
oui mais déjà salué sa passe à l'heure
où en un pays et qui a l'impression de
perdre toutes ses valeurs de souligner
cette valeur des citoyennes de tous les
personnels qui sont montés au créneau
pour sauver des vies c'est si beau on ne
le dira jamais assez on passe à la
politique si vous le voulez bien pour
s'intéresser à anne hidalgo
triomphalement on peut le dire élu maire
de paris aux dernières élections
municipales qui disait encore il ya
quelques mois qu'elle n'était pas
intéressée par l'échéance présidentielle
et puis voilà qu'elle est en train de
changer d'avis elle en dit un peu plus
dans une interview à nos confrères du
point
je prendrai toute ma part dit elle elle
aimerait bien fédérer le courant
écologiste avec le courant social
démocrate est ce que c'est une bonne
idée
cette cette candidature patrick peloux
elle doit vous réjouir parce que vous
vous avez été un soutien d'anne hidalgo
ah bah moi j'apprécie anne hidalgo je
trouve que c'est c'est quelqu'un pour
pour la connaître c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement intelligent de pub menaces
et de moderne dans sa façon d'approcher
les problématiques de notre société donc
qu'elle participe au débat alors que
c'est plutôt morne plaine
à gauche il faut s'en féliciter ça fait
partie du pluralisme
maintenant est-ce qu'elle ira ira pas la
présidentielle j'en sais rien je n'ai
jamais posé la question je ne sais pas
mais à mon avis elle a des choses à dire
et elle peut expliquer notamment sur des
sujets moi qui me tiennent à coeur comme
la laïcité comme la coopération entre
les entre les différents systèmes de la
société
de lutter contre la pauvreté et
favoriser la réindustrialisation en
france pour qu'on réussisse à ravoir des
entreprises et il les faire revenir en
france ça tout ça si si elle peut faire
avancer ces sujets c'est intéressant
laurent alexandre vous êtes aussi fan
que patrick peloux je pense qu'il ya un
créneau pour anne hidalgo le suicide
actuel de l'écologie politique et
d'europe écologie laisse un créneau anne
hidalgo pour faire la synthèse de la
gauche laïque non islamo gauchiste
c'était report la france a soumises
et puis des verts alors c'est vrai que
parce que la candidature jadot va être
rendue difficile par le courant des
nouveaux maires qui sont en train de
proposer une mesure punitive chaque jour
entre l'interdiction la 5g
l'interdiction du tour de france
l'écologiste parisien hier qui
expliquait que les gens qui regardaient
le tour de france étaient des espèces de
beauf des chômeurs sur leur canapé avec
un mépris de classe que marie-antoinette
n'auraient même pas osé avoir donc oui
il y as compte tenu du comportement
actuel des ayatollahs verts un créneau
qui se referme un peu pour yannick jadot
c'est pour ça que la femme de yannick
jadot jadot à la télé la semaine
dernière à dire ils nous sortent une
connerie par jour les maires à l'aimer
revers est en réalité la mauvaise passe
que ils sortent plus d'une connerie par
jour les ayatollahs verts qui ont pris
les villes que l'on connaît donc oui y'a
pour anne hidalgo une possibilité de
récupérer l'électorat vert qui va fuir
europe écologie si les khmers verts
continuent à garder le pouvoir et a gêné
la candidature de deux jadot donc elle a
un créneau et d'ailleurs il serait
souhaitable qu'il y ait une gauche
moderne une gauche de marché une gauche
sociale une gauche humaniste non islamo
gauchiste en france parce que de voir
finalement aucun espace entre macron qui
est un homme du centre droit et puis les
insoumis islamo-gauchiste ça fait quand
même mal au coeur il faut un courant de
il faut un courant de centre gauche il
faut un courant de gauche laïque
humaniste qui a disparu la france ne
peut pas avoir que un grand parti
bourgeois de gauche et droite qui est le
maquereau nisme en marche
et puis à côté des partis extrémistes à
droite et à gauche donc une gauche
humaniste reconstruite autour d'anne
hidalgo
ce serait une bonne chose pour pour la
la politique française pour conforter
votre votre analyse sur la capacité d'al
gore a rassemblé regarder ce sondage
ipsos qui montre que elle ferait une
bonne candidate
bien sûr celle et ceux ci pour les
socialistes de 37%
c'est moins bien que benoît hamon quand
même un qui arrive encore largement en
tête furieusement ça leur a pas servi
2017 m'enfin va il faut bien ce qu'ils
veulent et mais aussi une bonne
candidate pour 42% des écologistes et
pour 38% des électeurs de la france
insoumise et du parti communiste donc
effectivement une une capacité à
rassembler ou peut-être à faire le grand
écart patrick peloux non le le truc
c'est que toute façon s'il y a plus de
sept candidats de gauche à l'élection
présidentielle ils seront pas au
deuxième tour
donc voilà l'équation elle est
extrêmement simple
maintenant il ya des problèmes
absolument de fonds et e je suis un peu
lassé en fait de cette classe politique
qui survole les problèmes qui les prend
pas à bras le corps pour justement
notamment améliorer le quotidien des
françaises et français
c'est pour ça la sortie notamment de
xavier bertrand sur la sécurité ce
week-end je pense qu'il a raison il ya
vraiment un problème sur la sécurité la
sécurité globale pour tout le monde
d'accord deuxièmement la gauche s'est
perdue quand elle a confondu laïcité
racisme c'est à dire quand ils ont cru
que d'appliquer la laïcité ça devenait
un acte raciste pas du tout la laïcité
c'est prendre tout le monde dans la
république avec la tolérance et chacun
croit ce qu'il a entre les oreilles
c'est la croyance mais ça ne dépend pas
et ça ne prend pas le pouvoir en france
et qui sont certains fidèles laïcs
d'anne hidalgo
mais elle est assez discrète sur ce
sujet moi j'ai pas vu de prise de
position publique sur le voisin souvent
par l'aiea
avec elle et quand je les ai soutenus là
pour la campagne des municipales c'était
vraiment la première chose je pense que
justement il faut plus qu elles soient
discrètes là-dessus accord c'est à dire
que vraiment la défense de la laïcité en
france
alors je sais bien on va nous dire mais
oui mais là on est le seul pays au monde
pratiquement à parler de laïcité mais
quand vous voyez par exemple le
développement de la turquie
c'était l'époque où la laïcité était
devenue un objectif politique de la
turquie
l'aer dogan est devenu vraiment facile
et c'est l'islam au pouvoir ici en train
de tout casser il essaye de refaire la
guerre de troie c'est un carnage bon bah
là on aurait besoin d'entendre la classe
politique française abonnés absents ils
ne prennent pas parti
c'est pour ça que là on a une pauvreté
en termes de classe politique laurent
récente que pensez vous de ce point de
vue darcos guy sur youtube qui nous dit
hidalgo est entendue et reconnue dans le
microcosme parisien des nantis écolo
bourgeois dans le reste du pays
elle serait plutôt rejetée c'est vrai
que c'est plutôt la gauche des nantis
bien sûr si anne hidalgo veut gagner une
présidentielle il faut qu'elle élargisse
au delà des bobos du marais qui
représente une niche écologique qui ne
permet pas de prendre le pouvoir en
france donc il faut être capable de
parler aux gilets jaunes il faut être
capable d'avoir un discours qui ne soit
pas un discours écologiste méprisant
vis-à-vis des classes populaires de
légionellose roulant diesel mais et
et ils fument leur clé comme dj koze
cardinal de s'éloigner du discours de
mépris vis-à-vis des gilets jaunes que
europe écologie a aujourd'hui comme on
l'a vu ces derniers jours
je pense qu'elle est capable de faire
cette synthèse et d'élargir son corps
électoral vient au delà de l'électorat
bobo me parisien et je voudrais jamais
ya juste un signe qui montre peut-être
ça dans cette interview dont je parlais
elle dit je suis je sais qui je suis une
femme issue de l'immigration
né en espagne et naturalisée française à
14 ans je viens d'un milieu ouvrier
avec une maman couturière et un papa
électriciens les fins de mois difficiles
j'ai connu oui oui çà çà çà çà montre
son attachement au côté populaire et
c'est vrai qu'elle a quelques elle
comprend bien alors la remarque de
l'internaute là c'est pas recevable
parce que en fait qu'ils connaissaient
emmanuel macron deux ans avant la pré la
présidentielle personne
ah non là mais voilà donc cesser c'est
un truc on ne sait pas comment ça va
évoluer
et puis moi je récuse totalement l'idée
que la vie politique en france d'abord
ce quinquennat est une connerie il faut
bien il faut revenir au septennat ça
c'est un autre débat mais d'un coup tout
l'alpha et l'oméga tournerait autour de
la présidentielle je sais pas si vous
avez vu le second de la république en
marche qui vient de démissionner ça
montre que on a beaucoup cru il ya eu
beaucoup d'espoir avec l'arrivée d'un
jeune nouveau qui n'est pas issu des
partis politiques qui a jamais été élu
etc
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait bah c'est pas
ça non plus donc il faut avoir un débat
politique
avant de savoir qui sera le candidat
faut un débat de fond et un débat
politique ou là en effet une
personnalité comme anne hidalgo elle
peut en effet mieux se faire connaître
dans dans le pays et porter des choses à
mon avis positive est intéressante pour
le débat démocratique
vous écoute sûrement avec intérêt
puisqu'ils sont pas encore totalement
convaincu si on en croit ce petit
questionnaire expresse que nous leur
avons proposé sur twitter anne hidalgo
est elle une bonne candidate pour la
gauche en 2022
c'est non à 81% et dans ses arguments il
ya celui enfin les arguments critiques
qui à celui de françois sur lefigaro.fr
elle n'a déjà pas les toffes de la
capitale alors du pays n'en parlons pas
et puis archos guy encore lui qui nous
dit laurent alexandre haut niveau écolo
hidalgo est plutôt sectaire est centrée
sur ses idées sans contestation vous la
politique de circulation dans l'idéal go
à paris vous vous signer dès demain vous
avez un peu de re de critiques alors je
vis à bruxelles
donc je connais très bien la circulation
à bruxelles un peu moins bien à paris je
me sens moins concerné non mais c'est
hyper stratégique c'est une question de
santé publique faut mieux ré à paris
c'est pas possible que les parisiennes
et parisiens et cinq ans d'espérance de
vie de moins
parce que si si avec une pollution de
l'air alors ça diminue que ça diminue et
je pense que là ça sera positif juste
une remarque avant que ça se termine la
classe politique doit s'engager sur la
démocratie et rendre obligatoire le vote
comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs je crois
en belgique où il faut impérativement on
peut pas laisser des élections
intermédiaires comme celles qui ont eu
lieu ce week-end avec près de 80%
d'abstention il y avait un relatif
partiel et c'est ça c'est pas possible
que le on est un pays
je ne peux pas laisser dire ça sur la
pollution de l'air
si on prend les données officielles
d'airparif la pollution de l'air a été
divisée entre deux mille selon les
polluants à paris donc on ne peut pas
dire qu'on soit dans une phase
d'aggravation la pollution de l'air au
contraire les agressions sert à vendre à
paris grâce à hidalgo très bien commencé
en 1955 la chute serait allé d'ergo
n'était pas né voit mer notamment grâce
à l'amélioration de la qualité des
moteurs merci beaucoup à tous les deux
à ce rythme nous vous allez prendre
votre service wi lan capital hôpital
necker au samu de paris
et bien en 30 minutes on vous souhaite
une bonne continuation
merci beaucoup merci laurent alexandre
merci
[Musique]